unveiling the latest raft of sanctions
the u.s also cited sensational claims
made last year of russia offering
bounties to the taliban
on u.s troops in afghanistan the white
house admits it has very little to back
up those claims yet still it demands
answers from the kremlin
we felt the reports were enough of a
cause of concern
they assessed with low to moderate
confidence as you alluded to
that russian intelligence officers
sought to encourage taliban attacks
against u.s and coalition personnel in
afghanistan
so while there's load of moderate
assessment of
these reports we felt it was important
for our intelligence community to look
into it this information
really puts the burden on russia and the
russian government to explain
their engagement here in june last year
it was reported russian intelligence
offered taliban linked militants
bounties to kill
u.s troops in afghanistan in 2019. the
allegations were never proven and the
pentagon itself said that it could not
corroborate the reports but it didn't
stop the mainstream media from
going to town on the story
vladimir putin is offering
bounties for the scalps of american
soldiers in afghanistan now the european
intelligence official called this
callous shocking and reprehensible
overnight president
trump dismissed the intelligence denied
being briefed on it as new reports
emerged saying those payments did in
fact lead to the death of americans
you